more clues to the location of the first
domesticated cat exist inside modern
cats - also in their DNA
the reason domesticated cats found
anywhere in the world today are
descendants of just a few ancient groups
small numbers split off and migrated
around the globe each of these subsets
has less genetic variation than the
original population if lions can find
the group with the most genetic
variation she will have located the
closest descendants of the first
domesticated cats to obtain that data
Lions will look at more than ancient
dead cats she will need access to
thousands of living pets from around the
world all that's required is a little
saliva to reveal their DNA mutations
volunteers from around the planet will
collect these DNA samples from their
country's domesticated felines
as the mouth swabs arrived lions will
eliminate areas from the globe and hone
in on the geographic site of feline
domestication with a good sampling of
cats from all over the world we'll have
a very comprehensive study on cat
domestication all over the known cat
universe the team sends out swabbing
kits to the global recruits a search for
the first pet cat is underway
the alliance between humans and felines
is perhaps the most unlikely on earth
proud and self-reliant cats come and go
on their terms they don't need us
felis catus can take care of itself the
domestic cat is one of the most Hardy
animals on earth
an ingenious feline form allows it to
thrive in some of the planet's most
hostile environments living alongside
penguins on islands near Antarctica
on the Galapagos chain with little
freshwater cats get by they flourish as
scavengers in big cities and gypsies in
rural outposts
over 600 million claim residents in
households across six continents and now
they may have dethroned the dog as the
most popular pet on earth so where did
it come from